what was the most toughest like boxing
movie had to do
yeah I would say just the whole thing
this is the whole thing no one specific
move that came to mind do you know how
many moves we did in this movie do you
only think of one nah they're all tough
after a certain point now Jonathan a few
weeks ago told me that you're currently
his best friend Michael B Jordan is my
cut man and probably currently My Best
Friend
in Me
[Music]
no I mean he's definitely one of my best
friends man it's like he I got a brother
the way you know we've kind of connected
over the past couple years is something
special so yeah man he's right there in
the mix with my with my other best
friends like he's a part of the crew now
so like for sure